Let's jump back into May, I just quickly, one thing I didn't test, didn't have
a look at was, what's that month actually, profitable.
It was profitable.
So really slow, February 8%, March, 3.5%, April, 1%, with a really shocking win
rate.
April's win rate was 1.16%, 12.5%.
That's not what we're going for, that's a terrible seller score.
Cool, let's continue, let's get back into the month of May.
Okay.
So we're still bullish, and it is the first of May.
I have ISM manufacturer, there's no shift in there.
Ah, we just, I mean technically, but I still wouldn't have been tagged in
because my entry would have been all the way down here somewhere, probably this
one hour, which doesn't get tagged in.
I'm going to do it after the session, and I'm going to straight through that
session.
Really, we're building such a massive pocket of liquidity across these lows.
I'll swing low, we're still here, these price action honestly is.
And far, probably bad.
Cool, we've just shifted bearish.
Not sure I'm from there.
How am we just shifted bullish again?
One shift bearish again, no.
Cool, one to the third of May.
One to the third of May.
Cool.
Also, this is our swing low.
Fourth of May.
Third of May, we have deposit interest rates later.
That's bearish.
It's interest rates.
Cool.
The bearish.
Third of May, that's enough paper over.
Yep.
So we are, we are bearish.
We may get something in a lot of the session.
See what actually happens here.
That's not a pull bear.
That's technically a shift.
Well, most probably.
We're bearish from up here.
All the way to down here.
So this is M1 internal.
This I see is mitigation.
Turned out mitigations.
This area I'm really looking for.
And that is our session.
Complete.
That's our fee.
We should don't want to hold through anyway.
We are bearish from this high now.
Remember that eighth of May.
We are, we are bearish.
We don't have news.
And we are bearish.
Oh, it wouldn't be long in there.
Now we have Asian loves in play.
We are technically bearish.
I really don't like it.
That's just a liquidation for me.
That's the combination of that.
That wouldn't have been such a nice short.
That had such a great possibility to be a great short.
But we are probably bullish, which I don't agree with, but who am I?
I shift.
At least when you're wrong, but wrong, you don't have to say trades.
There's no news and I expected.
10th of May, we have inflation rates, which is later.
There's no news and there's no news to be.
Time is a three forty five.
Nope.
New York.
Still bearish.
Thursday 11th of May.
PPI, but it's later.
This is a really frustrating process.
It's like really frustrating process.
Stop New York.
We're not going to get a trade in New York session.
Technically not a pullback.
Friday 12th of May.
10 Michigan consumer.
Let's have a look at what we have here.
There's the M1 structure.
The M1 structure is going to be something like this, isn't it?
So we're going to have to go in time anyway.
Which means that probably isn't even an entry anyway.
Now it's in play.
Nope.
It's up, but it is still.
Maybe like, I don't know how many trades are taking.
In this month.
It's probably discretion, but it's also probably London.
So you can only go internal if the external is already bearish.
Something we spoke about in a few different lessons.
This is a strong point of interest in itself.
It's not first trade in May.
That would be a reversal.
That is under the 50th.
No news.
This is just not nice.
It's very rare occurrence that you get.
I thought I seen it, but I was like, maybe not.
I was like, okay, let's wait to see.
Maybe we get a trade and if we do, then I can look at it properly.
There's three kind of pullback, but what is this?
This is market close market open as well.
That's what makes it the most disgusting.
Let's just set it out for now.
What was that?
My expectation lot of flow is bearish.
There's another little bit more context as well.
I would be expecting lower prices.
We have to sweep Asia high anyway, which we do.
Thank you.
I'm not sure what's doing this situation.
That's what I would execute.
It's the M15 level.
No news.
I could put it in market down as discretion.
Again, all discretionary trades are going to be coming back to and looked at.
We can build a principle because I just don't understand.
This is what's throwing me off.
If I was personally objectively trading it in the live market, especially here,
I would be executing this without a shadow of love.
It's a little bit different when price is down here.
It's a lot more hesitant because it's not really much context.
When price starts getting up here and actually now has liquidity to build up,
we can see.
We can put it down as discretion anyway.
It's not that big of a deal.
We technically get executed at the 5am candle.
Maybe we get to break even break quick anyway.
Nope.
We put it down as discretion because it's a tricky one.
Honestly, I would probably take it in the live market.
I can't technically say that it's N15 pro trend.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
This is also difficult to say how am I supposed to explain what the structure
flow is because I don't even know if price is bullish or bearish.
Let's just go with its bearish because objective, that's why I would be trading
.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And the actual direction of flow is also like super bearish.
I would want to be sure in this.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's go with it.
It's bearish.
Let's just ignore this.
It's not like it's an actual pullback continuation.
Share.
I don't know if that's all good stuff.
I don't know what it is.
It's just noise.
I'm not going to put my stop at London High.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Turn.
No.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Can't catch more.
Wednesday 17th.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Building apartments.
And continuation.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's not going to be an entry there.
CM1 is the same.
I knew it would be.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's my break.
There's technically a bullish shift.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
A bearish again.
This for me is just, I would just never try to short.
I would wait for a sweep of the highs.
I would be more interested in trading that discretion.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We're going to have to assume bullish.
Only second of May.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We are bullish.
This could be an entry.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, hold on a second.
And we are bullish externally.
This is internal.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Or she does M5.
I value up.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I wanted to.
The best we can do is this.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's the best we could do.
I don't think so.
Nope.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
What is this?
I'm still honestly expecting lower prices.
Like you just zoom out and have a look.
And now the fact that we're loading up in this region.
That tells me that we're going to get lower prices.
We have no notice.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
This structure is just a mess.
What even is this?
We're bearish on a long, just a mess.
But the M1 is bearish.
It can't belong.
I also anyway think price is going lower.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's pretty much guaranteed to be a breakeven.
M3 inverted.
I got which is M5 odd block.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Also takes the position.
At this point, nothing meets with it again in this area of price specifically.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
May have honestly moved my stops there.
I know that this area is obviously still a metered.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Honestly.
It's a good chance that would be my stop below this low.
Of course, maybe I put it here, maybe not in the live market, but it's coming
below this low.
And that should technically take me out for half a percent.
That should tend to be a loss.
I want another day of the edge obviously.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Can we get out of this price action already?
Okay, we are now bearish.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Honestly.
20, 24, 20, 25, a million times better price action.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's not the cleanest, but when there are 24th of May.
If I'm seeing, hmm, that's a major.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The rest reward just isn't there.
Yeah, we can use that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I heard us make it one to five as well.
Why not?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And stops.
The rest reward on that's disgusting.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
This price action is a joke.
Try to quickly make sure that this trade doesn't run through.
Go for our journal.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's four, four or five.
We did hold this thing through IFO business climate.
But to me, that's just like meh.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No news.
25th.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yes, it's a really poor win rate for this year so far, still profitable.
Still good management and also still although poor win rate, you'll see that
the winter loss ratio is predominantly above five.
That was two to three AM.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Technically.
Better just collect the data, at least.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Good management.
That's news.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Honestly, probably should choose the high.
Same thing again, if both ones are high, it's running the other high.
With an extreme amount of confidence in that statement.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I have a few days left.
Let's break even.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And pretty seamless.
It's a much cleaner setup than all the rest.
Like this up here, the equal highs in the middle.
But still not really happy with the performance so far.
Objectively.
But I also understand that it's still an insufficient amount of data.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's a board.
Think about the point of realizing as well that I don't really think the point
of interest matter.
Maybe I'm wrong.
I'll know for sure, better when I go deeper into detail.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
29, we have nothing.
That would give us some.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I felt like.
I had a feeling it would be.
I don't know, it just felt smaller.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
In regards to total take profit, seven and a half are.
Bearish on a block.
Could refine it but I'm not trying to be like a perfectionist.
That's the type of stuff that gets you in trouble.
I don't think price trades above here but there's still a fair value gap as
well.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's a really solid point of interest as well, to be honest.
Probably not.
We'll keep it on this area.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Test such a clean reaction.
My stops.
Essentially a break even.
It must be real.
Let's see. Where's my wall?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That would be target.
It's really clean for it actually.
It's kind of the nuances.
It's like, right now we're taking every liquidation over Asia High, even if we
're pro trained,
even if it's not from an area of interest right as part of the testing phase.
I'm still, I still believe, again, this is kind of something I wish I added.
It's like my personal opinion of an A+ set up because then at least at the end
when I get all of the context back and all the testing and all the data.
I can go and look at like, how's my objective opinion, my subjective opinion,
should I say, on these different setups.
Because then I'll know as well, like have a deeper knowing and confidence in my
own analysis.
For example, like this is the type of setup that I look at as an A+ set up.
Regardless of what I know is the data, like I've seen this set up play out so
many times.
We're bearish.
We're in the premium of the price leg, right?
We've just had a huge sweep of liquidity across to the left that's caused us.
Like there's so many underlying context.
There's so much underlying context that supports the hypothesis of the setup.
Do you want to excuse me?
Okay.
This structure flow thing is just literally a waste of time.
I'm probably not going to get tried this day.
So if of me.
Wait.
Could New York.
That's so sad.
Because I actually think the price of trade law.
I think it had this exact thing last time you remember.
This is so unsurprising.
31st.
So we have a bunch of inflation rates in London session.
That's the first.
I will just take that low.
I knew it was going to trade lower.
Why did it have to close above that high?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That's the first of June.
Shift to bearish. There's no trades.
We don't short here because we didn't see how to have it taken.
We're bearish. So there's no shorts. There's no positions here.
So that's fine. We didn't actually miss any trades.
Which is the versus June.
I think May was a little bit better.
No, not a little bit.
It was a better month.
But I still think that there just wasn't that many positions.
That wouldn't trade much.
Five trades.
Terrible win rate.
Better Zella score.
Yeah, not great. Draw down.
And obviously win percentage.
Profit factors improved.
We have a great average win to lose.
Average win to losing. Yeah.
Winning to lose in trade ratio.
That's very much April. May.
Very much April, May.
That's 18 months of data we have now.
Like every single day, day in day out.
Eighteen months.
We have a total of.
I'll be well at 150 trades now.
Total trade in 846.
Total number of trades, 172 trades.
So now we have data of 172 trades.
Which is a lot nicer.
Number of winning trades.
45.
Number of losing trades.
88.
Four break evens.
And that four break evens like almost all of them.
Have been.
Save this money.
That's a really great quick of.
Still not finished yet because we haven't finished 1-2-3.
It goes from 2-3 to 3-3 to 2-3-4.
That's a really nice accurate curve.
Almost not a single setup is negative.
Of the New York sweep Asia which has probably been barely any trades.
One trade.
One trade and it was a partial loss.
New York sweep London.
13 trades.
Practically break even.
Discretion.
19 trades.
25% return.
The annoying thing is in the first 2024 test we used current balance.
Which is actually honestly annoying.
Because the final kind of six months.
Yeah.
It's not ideal at all.
But discretion.
For example here we understand now.
If we go in here we're pretty much going to understand.
Because they're all part of setups.
We're going to pretty much understand the ones that attacked only discretion.
They are trades that are, I think, a purely discretion.
No, that's not true.
What about session?
Is New York still far better than?
Nope.
Oh, this is.
No, New York is still better.
But London is catching.
But double game out of trades taken in London.
Just more far more losers in London.
Lower win rate as well.
See, 27% win rate in London.
Still a good equity curve.
But 27% win rate in London.
New York has 41% win rate with a much higher profit factor.
So I think London may be the, whether real work is done in terms of
optimization.
Let's have a look if we have any of this sort of stuff.
We have zero unprofitable execution windows.
Nothing that's unprofitable on news, premium discount.
I thought so, it doesn't make a difference.
At least that tells you.
We don't know for sure because you have to add things together as well.
But individually, in and of itself, on its own, there is no statistical
significance in just premium discount alone.
Same with the phase of trend.
Essentially, I want to just prove the hypothesis of a structure flow that's
pretty much just because they're all taken like that.
Sasha, I'm a bean throw point of interest.
This is interesting because weak points of interest really don't work well.
Basically break even. And I bet you, if we go apply that to a bunch of
different setups, for example, if we do.
If we do weak point of interest with.
Let's have a look at this.
Oh, wait, that's just what I did, apologies.
If we go do, let's say.
It's the London subs that we, that we struggle with.
That you can already see it.
So in and of itself, that there, that is what set up.
That's the London, when London sweeps Frank into a weak point of interest.
We're not doing so well. There's only six ups.
So, yeah.
London sweep Asia.
Also not doing really great.
You can see how a better strong point of interest is though.
Like I could quite literally just avoid all of these trades, which is just
unnecessary.
Room for error, right? You want to see trades.
Realistically, like.
A trade is.
An opportunity.
But it's also.
A window for a window of error.
So.
If I can reduce how many trades I take.
Then I believe because they have to make fewer decisions, I will be able to
make better decisions.
So, for example, because they hear that these already all of these London
setups, right?
Let's take Frank for as well.
Let's take Frank for sweet reversal.
Already, what I can tell you is 21 trades, where I've used a weak point of
interest.
I'm I've lost.
6.8%.
I don't know of which of that's the problem as well.
Like, one of those trades could have ended up being one where I was basically
risking $20,000.
That's the problem of testing how I tested. So, make sure you test it on.
Start and balance, but the point is, is that's 21 trades.
All for the London setup.
That I could have just avoided and even just avoiding those trades.
Would have would have saved me 6.8% and maybe even the broad ones as well.
4.8.
But there's fewer of those.
You can quite clearly see the strong points of interest with these specific
setups, which is what the A+ setup is anyway is by far the most profitable.
But that is what the A+ setup is.
If you watch the last trade I took and I put A+ next to it, that is what that
was.
It's the sweep of liquidity with a strong point of interest, right?
Because a strong point of interest is already inside a premium or discount.
Most likely.
And okay, let's move on to the next session.